je m'appelle josée boily et je suis né
en janvier 2001 à akébé dès mon plus
jeune âge j'ai démontré une intensité
incroyable constance
une persévérance à toute épreuve dans
tout ce que j'entreprends passionné de
pêche et de géologie
je crois en mes rêves et je les
réaliserai tous avec brio n'y a aucune
limite pour moi les relations entre frei
sort je me connais puis un frère et
d'une soeur ou l'espèce de ma main vous
livrer mes observations et miss est
cette façon est un an et most mon père
mon frère
la relation entre franc et sort s'il
peut toujours facile une question pour
vous qui s'ils ont un frère ou une soeur
lever la main et souffler vous voyez ça
consomme beaucoup de gens ici
ceci mon frère je vous aime chose dit
vraiment mais vraiment à nous
grandeur et qu'après ado s'est passé
parce qu'on se bat pau tribunal
c'est comme l'audio j'éteins mon chalet
et la pompe était gelé alors il fallait
aller où toi et d'or à un moment donné j
talus ou très tôt et le faisait super
beau mais le sait la nuit maison et loue
mon frère hype à bahia ils prennent un
air où la neige comme ceux en âge comme
ce qui ne gâche tout ce que tu veux dire
que ma bon mais moi j'étais vraiment
fâché c'est comme aussi qu'un que
jacques hf cleans pieux j'ai montré à
marc marquez que j'arrive en a 400 qui j
po a clash éclate entre ce que moi
jacques l'âge de 15 ans et je pense que
si un des jeux sur la table est le plus
joué au monde
et là j'ai connu besoin à bula want to
de sorcier il un clash appelé instinct
économise se peut prendre longtemps et
économise de l'or et j'économise et
j'économise et j'étais presque rendu
avant ma tour de sursis cac montfrin et
avait pas des mots harrachis l'ipad est
moins que commencer a tenu tout bible
ton faille premièrement j'étais fauché
deuxièmement reste à 0,5
c'est comme si quelqu'un joue au final
qu ils le savent user 30 minutes qui
m'ont fois voulait pour surtout dans le
match et soro solo mais le mont franc
sorti dans est le premier mouvement que
fait il à dire ceci ma balle est faute à
bâle alors le shalit sur saint omer et
elle a dit les ouvrant à 30 d'un plug
ins d'asthme aurait donc j'ai vraiment
un bond
faits scientifiques prouvé sur les
relations entre froid enfin on pense
plus je t'ai avec notre foi que nous par
un nos professeurs nous amis et même
qu'être seul jusqu'à 11 ans oppose 33 %
de notre temps avec quatre fois les
français charmant et beaucoup n'hésitent
ils ont démonté qui est des trous à 7,1
cette fois vont avoir trouvé le conflit
à la savoure aperçu du sommet pour
seconder fois ou du soir une grosse
partie à tracter se développe dans les
cars action à une autre sphère par
exemple lors de conflits apprendre à
résoudre celui ci peut être utilisée
plus tôt dans sa vie
d'autres études ont démontré que dans
nos familles nos grands froids ils ont
grandi en influence sur les pigeons
comment mon frag vont expirer le sport
et la vie patients dans les sports et
l'esprit dans la natation le football et
le badminton et demie patients mesrine à
la collection et c'est mon frère mon
meilleur ami passent plus mes dynamise
études mais ce beau nom dans la famille
comme de l'humour la joie et plein
d'autres choses
et en plus de me rendre des services
pour moi c'est une personne très
importante très fiables m'ont fra grm
comme qu'il est sa façon unique de
procéder est de plus en plus comme à
vire on se rend compte que notre frère
et la personne qu'on peut le plus
compter sur lui un bref mon frère je
laime merci